大家好 欢迎来到数据要素可信流通技术穆克
我是这节课程深入理解TES的主讲人田鸿亮
首先稍微介绍一下我自己
我是一个操系统跟系统安全方面的一个研究者
在这两个方向有不少的论文发表
同时作为一个工业者的研究者
我其实也是一个开发者
我非常热衷于去开发安全优关的系统软件
包括给TES 包括给精明计算使用的软件
在过去几年里我主要的重心是在研发开源的TES
我是两款开源TES的发起者和主要的设计师加过师
那一款叫Oculus
它是目前给Intel SDS这种Uncleave的最受欢迎
最流行的酷操系统LiberaS
这个工作在Splows220上面有发表
目前开源项目有1.5K Github Star
那在最近几年我的重心转向去给
包括机密VM
也包括更加通用场景去做这种安全和高效操系统
所以我发起了一个叫Assyrinus星战的项目
它是一个可以兼顾安全跟效率的通用的OS内核
可以给TES 但是可以给更多的领域去用
这个工作Splows220上面
目前这个开源项目有3.5K Github Star
那正是因为过去几年我在TES方面的这些工作跟积累
是说我自己还是比较有信心
可以把TES这个话题给大家能够去讲好
这一节课程我主要会讲三方面的东西
第一部分会比较前线一些
这是一个对TES的一个引入
第二三部分会介绍TES或者说这位整个TES
最大的安全威胁就是所谓的Iago攻击
我会分享
第二部分会分享
Iago attack如何去攻击TES和TES的内存安全性
然后以及怎么防范
然后第三部分会介绍说
Iago attack如何去在TES或者TES
在做文件IO的过程中去攻击它
然后我们怎么去防范
二三部分会更加深入
技术上也会更加难一些
这方面的工作我们分别是在ATC25
跟FAST25两个会议上有相应的顶会论文的发表
好
我们就进入第一部分
什么是TES呢
首先我们OS大家每天都在用
OS可以说是有非常多的定义
我觉得在我们这里我们可以把OS定义成
它是上层的这些应用
跟底层的硬件之间的一个桥辆
那TES就是TES的应用
跟TES的硬件之间的一个桥辆
那我们可以大致的把TES分成两大类
或者说在这个课程里面
我们会主要讲这两大类
那一类是所谓的unclaves
就像intelSGS
这个里面你一般会去用
所谓的库槽型Liberwise
因为这里的OS它是跟应用程序
连接在一起的
因为这个是用户态
你并不是真正有一个特形态的OS
所以是一个库槽型Liberwise
比如说HavenSGSLKL Grammaric Opalum
这个后面我们都会简单的去过一过
然后大家因为大家都知道
TES是逐渐从unclave这个形式
走向GIMI-VM-CVM
confinition-VM这个形态
所以在CVM里面的TES
就是一个所谓的gaswise
因为相对于VM-VM的素主机
HOSOS
这里就是gas
所以gasOS当然可以用Linux
也有比如说像GrammarT.es
这样的研究性的TES的工作
也包括我这边去做的Srinus
我们来非常快速的回顾一下
TES的一些发展历史
Haven是第一个给unclave SGS
去构建的一个库槽系统
这个是在OSDI14年发表的
Haven如图中
黄色部分unclave区域里面中间
就是Liberwise
这个是DropRage
Liberwise它提供的是Windows的这种功能
Windows的API
上面可以跑不经修改的Windows的用程序
DropRage它没有太考虑TES里面的一些特点
所以为了把这个Liberwise能够移植到unclave环境里面
所以Liberwise下面会有一个叫Shield
一个防护罩的模块
这一边它就负责向上层的Liberwise
提供一些必要的素主机环境的支持
因为我们知道unclave它是一个在用户态的用TES的技术
它不能去做特权的事情
所以Liberwise必须要透过Shield module
来去找unclave外面的不可信的素主机环境
来去比如说创建线程去做调度去申请
或者是管理一些虚拟内存
去用hostOS里面提供的文件系统
等等这些功能
所以这是Haven功能它的一个基本的架构
从右边Table一众可以看到
DropRageLiberwise本身还是很大的
它有几百万行的代码
因为它要提供完备的Windows的API
而Shield的模块相当来说就比较小了
只有几万行
这个是第一个库操性的工作
它是一个很重要的里程碑
它可以使多一个不经修改的Windows应用程序
就可以直接方便的移植到了unclave环境里面
就是自动的就把它保护起来了
所以这是一个很好的工作里程碑
在此之后GrammarSJS
ATC17上发表的论文
它做的就是说
因为Windows毕竟不是开源的
在机密计算的领域里面
更多的大家跑的是Linux应用程序
所以GrammarSJS
这是一个Linux兼容的
一个支持单净程的一个库操系统
整体来说它的架构
如这个图索是其实跟黑文是差不多的
就是上面这里的可执行程序
就是应用程序了
下面会link各种各样的库
最底下的库当然就是LibC
LibC会去接上LiberOS
这里Grammar的LiberOS
他们专门去单独写的LiberOS
从头写的
所以就比较精简
在LiberOS下面
是为了这个LiberOS
去适配速度机环境
来去有这么一个电骗屋层
也是世界交suit的
这个suit的部分
就有类似于黑文那边
也要提供比如说
线程 调度 稳定系统
等等这些LiberOS
作为一个用户谈程序
做不了的事情
同时当然也会做一些
跟安全有关的事情
所以总体价格来说
跟黑文也是很像的
但是Grammar sjs
有一个很大的好处
就是它的LiberOS
是它从头写的
所以这个LiberOS
它是远比黑文
是要轻量的 小的
所以从这个角度上来说
在uncleave里面的
这些可信代码
LiberOS
它就占的量就比较小
相对来说
就会更加可信
不容易有一些安全漏洞
这个是Grammar sjs
这个工作相对于黑文的进步
在Grammar sjs之后
Alcum工作
就是是我们来去做的
Alcum是在Splus20上发表的
它相对于Grammar
对于来说
相同点在于说
Alcum也是提供的是Linux兼容的
这种OS的接口
可以去跑
不经修改的Linux用程序
但是Alcum好的点在于什么呢
第一
它可以在一个uncleave里面
可以去跑多个进程
因为实际上
我们知道很多用程序
它是需要多个进程
去一起去协同去操作
比如说一个Shell
你每一行命令都是一个进程
所以多进程之时
对于应用的兼容性
其实是非常重要的
所以这个是Alcum
它在从single process
到multiprocess
这么一个
克服这么一个技术困难
另外就是Alcum
它是第一个用Rust写的LiberS
在此之前的这些LiberS
全都是用C写的
大家都知道
C的内存安全漏洞是
或者bug是很容易出现的
在提议这么一个
非常注重安全的环境的话
你用Rust内存安全的原去写
让LiberS应该可信
这是一个很大的安全的优势
所以这个是Alcum这个工作
不管是Haven
不管是Grammy
还是Alcum
它虽然试图去做Linux兼容
但是因为它毕竟不是Linux
所以它的兼容性肯定是要打折扣的
所以有人就做了一个工作
就是说我能不能把Linux
移植到unclave的环境里面呢
这个就是SSLkl的工作
Lkl是叫Linux Kernel Library
它就是一个把Linux从内核泰
port到用户台
作为一个库存在的一个项目
Lkl是一个
它并不是Linux在主线上的一个功能
它是一个autotrader一个独立的项目
所以有人就把Lkl又从普通用户台
移植进了SSL的环境里面
如左边这个图所示的
我们看到整体来说的话
还是一个三明治结果
就是最上层是用程序
然后是各种库
包括Lib C
然后接的是Lkl这么一个Lib S
Lkl这下面当然就会
这里它画蓝色的方块
就是一样是相当于是一个电片
或者说sure的层
让Lkl可以去访问
unclave by的宿主机提供的各种各样的
内存线程 信号 时间 还有这些功能
然后因为Lkl它是一个
毕竟是从Linux改的
所以Linux底下肯定是要接这种设备上做Io的
所以Lkl它的网络Io
就是要接Virtual Io的Network
然后Lkl它的quarkquark的文件Io
就需要接一个quark设备
Virtual Io的quark的设备
所以这个是Lkl的一个工作
到二一年之后
大家逐渐就认清了
未来的T1的形态
会从unclave转向GIMI VM CVM的形态
所以Grammen TDX的这个工作
它就是在想就是说
为CVM
比如说Intel TDX的CVM
为它去写TUS的话
那么我们应该去注意
现在有什么不同的支出呢
如左边架构图是
Grammen TDX呢
它是跑在
当然就是跑到Intel TDX
TD trust to make这么一个GIMI VM里面
这个里面
Grammen LibreOS
它就不再是跑用户态了
它就跑的是特权态
LibreOS本身基本上是不用改
LibreOS它放在SGS里面
还是用户态
还是放在TDS里面
这个代码是一样的
不同的支出在说
Grammen TDX
给LibreOS下面的适配层
做了一个叫TDS的后端
TDS后端它
因为现在就是
这个环境是在特权态了
所以你就需要自己去管页表
这里会增加页表管理
自己要管内存
包括自己要去实现
现成还有调度
然后以及比如说
你需要去处理中断
你真正然后下面
为了让Grammen TDX里面
做IO的这些部分的功能
是最小化的
所以它底下的LibreOS SOC
就接的是Wertio VSOC
这个协议
文件系统接的就是Wertio FS
然后我们中端
就接的是Wertio Console
所以Grammen TDX
它相对来说
它的代码量是会净减很多
你可以看到下面Table一种
它显示
如果我们在TDS
或者CVM里面跑Linux
这个是大概一手
200万行的代码量
这是非常大的
但是Grammen TDX
全部代码就是5万多行
所以这样子
使得说Grammen TDX
它声称我们的TCB
Trust Computing Base
TCB 可信计算机
你需要信任代码
这个量被缩小了
两个数量即一
相对来说
会比较有安全的优势
这是Grammen TDX工程
当然CVM里面
大家最常用
或者说默认使用的选项
当然就Linux
Linux对于CVM
也提供了很多方面
大家也给了Linux
贡献了很多CVM方面的一些支持
我觉得非常值得一提
Linux参加已经
加入了一个叫ConfigFS TSM
这么一个额外的功能
这个功能它解决的是
一个就是说你T1里面
如何让应用程序
T1里的应用程序
如何去拿远程证明的报告
就是attestation report
在ConfigFS TSM
出现之前
不同的T1
比如说SGS
或者是SEV or TDX
它们都会在Librize
或者是Linux Kernel这边
会去提供非常独特的一些
设备或者是接口
然后使得说用户它的用程序
可以去拿有硬件背书的
这个证明报告
这样的话
这个用程序
它其实就写下来很麻烦
因为它对于不同提议
它拿这个证明的方式是不一样的
而且在内核这边
每一种提议
你怎么去拿这个报告里面的代码
也有很多这个荣誉
所以ConfigFS TSM
出来之后就可以解决这个问题
就是它是一个统一的办法
可以使得说不同的提议平台
都可以用这个统一的方式
去拿这个报告
据它说就可以看下面这个简单粒子
就是说
所谓的ConfigFS
就是在SIGARN CIS
SIGARN kernel
SIGARN config
这个目录一般来说都会挂载
类似什么叫ConfigFS
一个特殊的一个sudo的
一个委文件系统
这个里面
就是一个纯粹是在内存中的
一个文件系统
它下面的操作
会在内核中
会有一些特殊的效果
那具体来说
这里的所谓的TSM
就是会增加了一个额外
叫TSM这么一个跟T
有关的一个额外的目录
你在这个目下
会有一个叫report的
一个特殊的目录
你在这个目下
你找随便去建一个目录
比如说叫myreport
这就说明
OK 用户态
现在它用程序
就想要拿到一个报告
你一旦建了这么一个空公路之后
你是建的是空公路
但是实际上
ConfigFS这边
会帮你在这个目录里面
会自动去建一些文件
比如说在myreport里面
会自动帮你建一个叫
outblob的特殊的文件
那你可以用它
你可以忘这个inblob
输入的特殊文件里面
你可以写
比如说写个nones
nones来保证
就是说
我们拿TSMreport
拿的是一个唯一的
防重放的攻击
所以第二步就是说
你要忘inblob文件里面
写个nones
写完之后
你去找myreport的
目录下的一个特殊的文件
叫outblob
从这个里面
你来去读
读出来
你要的attention
report
具体
这个硬件是怎么产生report的过程
完全是被
ConfigFS这边帮你给包起来
你不需要考虑这些细节
总之你只要写过inblob
文件之后
你就可以从outblob里面
读出来report
之后
因为你已经
拿到你想要的report
对吧
所以你就可以清掉
说这个目录
就万事大计
所以这个是
我们可以看
这是teos的一些眼镜
以及一些有代表性的teos
它的这个
一个盖了
所有teos都会面临
一个非常大的一个安全威胁
所有teos的敌人是谁呢
就是叫Iago attack
Iago攻击
Iago是什么东西
Iago其实是一个人名
Iago是Sachia的戏剧里面的一个角色
这个角色
就是说
它是一个大奸似中
花言巧语
想企图欺骗你的
这么一个反面角色
那为什么我们管
这个对tea的
这种攻击叫Iago attack
就是说
因为tea本身有硬件的
这个特性
保证了说
tee y的
这个速度计划
HOST OS
或者是hypervisor
它是无法直接的
不管是窃取tee里面的
内存或者CPU的信息
或者是修改tee里面的
CPU或者内存的信息
它是无法直接去攻击你的
所以它就得换一个
更加渐渐的办法
就是说
你tee
总是需要从我宿主
从环境这边
得到一些信息
对不对
你可以可能会去调我的
这种性能调用
可能去找我的hypervisor
要有些东西
那你在跟我交互的过程中
我故意给你伪造的
tee的虚假的内容
那这些内容
就可能会去误导
影响tee os里的
一些执行流
或者说它的一些决策
导致可以在tee os里面
出现问题
所以tee的应用程序
跟tee的os面临的
最大的攻击
最大的危险
就是iago attack
所以我们下面
就会介绍
就是说
到底对tee的
内存安全的iago attack攻击
是什么样子
以及iO的iago attack攻击
首先我们看
内存安全的攻击是什么样子
那我们下面都是
拿Linux来去举例
首先我们先来做一个小游戏
结果一什么就是
我们来看一看
下面一些Linux
内部的一些驱动代码
那这些代码
因为驱动
驱动就是要跟tee
就是要跟tee外面的
这些设备
女生有个交互
所以tee的Linux的驱动
它就必然会去
读取一些在tee外的
由tee跟host的共享的内存
这个内存里的信心
就是不可信的
那如果说
那既然这些信息是不可信的
这是不可信的输入
就有可能影响Linux内核
作为一个teos它的行为
那这就有可能让Linux
会去出发一些内存安全的问题
那我们来看一看
大家能不能从
我们下面举的这些代码里面
片段看出来
Linux到底会出现
什么样的内存安全问题
那这个第一个代码
这个片段展示的是
Virtual IO的
所有Virtual IO的设备
它底层都会用一个叫
Virtual IO queue的
这么一种传输的办法
就是一个
你可以往这个Q里面
去插一些request
或者是得到一些response
所以我们来看这么一个
Virtual IO queue
在这个代码里面
我们已经把不可信的输入
也就是说这里有一个叫
Descriptor
index.i.next
那这个内存
实际上就指向了
是一个tei的不可信的内存
那这个内存的
它的值
是完全可以受到
tei的攻击者控制的
那如果这个是不可信的话
会出什么问题呢
那因为
这个descript i
index.i.next
这个变量
它的值是不可信的
所以就会导致
index.i
这个变量i就是不可信的
那因为这个i
后面会作为
Linux内部的代码
它的一个index
那这个
如果可以随意
被攻击者控制的话
那就可以导致什么
导致buffer overflow
导致autobound access
那这就有可能
允许tei外的攻击者
去任意的去
读取或者是篡改
Linux内部的这些内存
从而就控制了Linux
那这是一个bug
那第二个bug
展示的是
这里同样是
这个virtail的驱动
那这个是virtail console
那这里的port device
它的max number ports
这个field
就是一个不可信的输入
这是这个设备
它的一个参数
所以肯定是由qmil
由tei的qmil拿去控制的
那所以呢
它同时它下面的port def
里面你可以去拿出来
一个multiport
这么一个信息
这个信息也是
有攻击者可以控制的
那如果这两个信息
是不可信的输入
那如果说
我们在Linux里面
代码完全不做任何
检查的话
会出什么情况呢
那我们可以看到
就是因为
这个number port这个变量
以及use multi port
它的结果
都是被攻击者可以控制
所以呢
就可以使得说
这个number port
加1x2这个事情
就可以可能会溢出
这个溢出就可以导致
这个一旦溢出
就可以导致就是说
这个number qs这个变量
它的值可能是0
而如果这个东西是0
那就会有一个
很奇怪的情况
因为下面它就会
拿这个number qs
这个长度
来去做一个
一个数组的maloch
那这个数组
现在你maloch
这个长度是0
那kmaloch array
给你返回了
这个vqs
这个数组
它的长度就是0
但是
就是说
分配这个vqs
这个长度
实际上分配的是0
或者是一个很小的东西
但是
但是Linux代码
其他部分
它并不认为
这个q长度是0
因为它这个
比如说number pose
它可不是0
所以这就会导致
就是后面访问vqs
就会出现
内存的
这个是
Autobot access
或者buffer overflow
那第三个
例如我们看
就是这个是vertile net
它在初始化prob
就是初始化
这个vertile net
设备的时候
会做的事情
这里这个mto
这个
这个也是一个
这个vertile net
这个设备
它的一个参数
那这个
这个参数
也是由qm这边
它去控制的
由这个t外的
虚拟的
这个vertile的
这个网卡设备
它去决定的
那这个mto
我们一般认为
一般认为这个mto
它是不会
不会是一个很小的数
所以呢
Linux里面有一个
你看到有一个路径
会看这个mto
是不是小于一个命mto
然后如果说
这个非常不
不应该发生的情况
它发生了
它就会go to free
就是我们就
那就出错处理吧
跳到free这个位置
然后return arrow了
那这个是它的逻辑
那如果说
这个mto是不可信的
会出现什么情况呢
那我们现在就代码
还有个问题就是说
它go to free之后
然后free
你看 free
这个label
你执行了free
def
netdef
那就会释放def
这个变量所在的这个指针的
试试完之后
那你下面要返回错码
对吧
那可是因为
我们这里
ifmto小于def
命mto这个 branch
它太少执行了
写这个代码人
它其实根本就不觉得
这个电话会被执行到
就会导致一个什么情况
就是在这个路径
实际上
这个函数里面
这个arrow
er这个变量
其实还是0
也就是说
比如说
如果供给者
这个
这个通过牙管探控制mto的话
就会导致一个
实际上它执行到了free
这个路径
然后这个def变量
它会被
它被free掉
这个指针
以后就不能用了
但是
这个return error
这个er是0
实际上就是说
return是成功了
这就会导致
这个调这个
不执行的probe的
这个函数
它以为自己成功了
但实际上
它的这个设备的
这个指针
已经被吸过了
这就会造成
这个after free的内传球问题
一旦有这种玩内传球问题的话
可能就会导致
这个t外的供给者
直接就完全
take control
off this Linux kernel
所以这是我举三个
这个
内存安全的漏洞了
当然这些漏洞都
都已经
其实在Linux
对这个t的支持的过程中
都已经被
发现识别
同时已经被加过或者解决掉了
但是这里
这是一个通用的
一个
这是一个
一类问题
就是说
Linux我们知道
它是由C写的
然后
据这个很多研究发现
就是说
像Linux这种由C
或Celj写的这种大型的
复杂的行动软件
有6-70%的安全漏
安全的
这个
严重安全的漏洞
全都是因为什么
更应都是在
内存安全的bar的
那
这个
现在的
在这个t环境里面
有Iago Tech
那
就会使得
内存安全的bar
它会就更多
据英台的统计
在Linux里
有超过1,500个
1,500处
不可性的输入
这个是会受到
t外来的攻击者影响的
那所以
为了让Linux
再用到t
放到t里面
放到cvm里面
不会受到Iago Tech的攻击
那实际上的
内核开发者
有了大量的
这种
审计工作
加固工作
测试工作
来去试图去防治
各种各样的这种可能
通过Iago Tech来去出发
内存安全bar的那种可能性
但是因为
这些驱动程序
实际上是很多
所以你很难说
这种
这种加固的路径
它能够系统性的
把所有Iago Tech都给防住
那所以呢
那个
有没有更好的办法呢
那
那我们这边就是
做了一个新的OS
叫SRITUS
那它可以
系统性的解决
内核的内存安全问题
包括
这个有Iago Tech因此
内存安全问题
那SRITUS
它是一个
前面也说
就是一个同时能够兼顾
安全跟效率的
一个通用的OS内核
它提供跟Linux
完全兼容的
这些性道用
或者是ABI
而它也是完全用RUS去写的
那
那为什么要做SRITUS呢
在SRITUS新战出现之前
其实也已经有别的
用RUS写的内核了
那当然大家都是觉得说
用RUS写的内核
应该是比C写的内核
更加内存安全一些
不容易有
内存安全的bug
然后同时
也就意味着不容易有
内存安全的漏洞
安全漏洞
但是实际上
并不是说你这个内核
你用RUS写
它自动就是
内核
那为什么呢
因为在RUS里面
有一个superpower
超能力
超能力叫安safe关键词
对安safe关键词
可以使得你做什么事情
比如说你可以去
可以去解引用罗指针
也就是说
你可以访问
任何一个物理地址
你可以去
插汇变代码
那汇变代码
当然就完全
没有任何安全可言
对吧
因为它都是机器代码
你写错一点点
都可能直接导致
出现一些
完全不可预测的行为
你可以用安safe关键词
你可以去调用一些
安safe的函数
比如说用CC的函数
那当然也就完全没有
内存权性可言
所以这个是在RUS里面
它有一个可以突破RUS的
类型系统限制的关键词
叫安safe
那一旦你用安safe的话
你不用安safe
你是纯safeRUS的代码的话
那它就是内存权的
但是你一旦用了安safe的话
这个你安safe的部分有可能有问题
它同时也可能会导致你safe的部分
也可能有问题
所以安safe还是一个
比较危险的事情
我们一般说RUS的语言
它是内存权权
可以解决内存权权问题
是因为我们一般来说
大家写的RUS写的程序
其实是应用程序
RUS一般来说
应用程序其实你也用不到
安safe的关键词
你可以不用
但是RUS内核
因为你要做很多很底层的事情
所以你不可避免的
你要用安safe的超能力
比如说你内核
你可能要去操纵CPU的计存器
操纵CPU这个事情就很危险
而且非常底层
你必须要用安safe
比如说你需要访问物理内存
也必须要用安safe
你可能你必须要配置自己的
你管理自己的站
管理自己的堆
你需要去做内核跟用户
用户在这边的switch
或者做connet switch
所有这些事情都是很底层的
你不用安safe关键词
这个代表是写不出来的
所以正是因为这个原因
所以在我们做sruns之前
我们看的这些RUS内核
我们都并不认为说
它彻底把内存存
内核的内存存这些事情解决了
所以我们就反思
之前的这些RUSS
它能不能做得更好
我们就提出了一个
我们认为是在RUST
语言这个时代
最适合操作系统内核的一个新的架构
这个架构我们可能要叫
框内核
叫frame kernel
frame kernel
这个idea它既有点像框内核
也有点像微内核
它像框内核的部分
就是说如左边这个图所示
整个框内核
它的所有的内核代码
都是在特存带
在同一个地质空间里面
这个就有点像框内核
但是框内核它的代码
要化分成两部分
一部分是蓝色的框架部分
我们叫OS Framework
OS框架
那这一部分
它是允许使用Unsafe Rust
它的角色就是说
它把整个内核里面的
所有的Unsafe代码
都吸收集中浓做到了框架部分
放到这个里面
然后把这个里面的
所有Unsafe的Rust代码
封装成为高层的
安全的Rust抽象
或者是Rust API
那这些Rust抽象跟API
就供蓝色的框架部分
它的里面的灰色的部分
这个我们叫OS服务部分
供这一部分去使用
这一部分
我们让它是
要求是纯粹的
安全的safe Rust去写的
不能有任何像Unsafe
那这个灰色部分
它负责去实现
这个OS里面的
几乎所有功能
比如说内存管理
进程管理
调度
文件系统
网络协议站
包括驱送程序
这个OS的绝大都是功能
都是用纯safe Rust
写的
然后在灰色的部分
那这样我们就可以
有一个很大的好事什么
就是说你整个内核里面
只有很少的一部分代码
就是说蓝色的框架部分
它是需要靠程序源
人工的审计检查
来保证说
没有内存的问题
而剩下的绝大多数的代码
可能是几百万行的量
它都是纯粹的safe Rust
而这一部分
完全是由Rust的编辑保证
只要能编译通过
那就没有内存的问题
所以这个是框内核
那框内核的那个
它的好处是什么
就是说它可以
假认言之
就是说它可以做到
红内核的性能
和微内核的安全性
我们在这个图里面
把红内核
微内核
还有框内核
放在一起比较了
就是因为这个框内核
跟红内核一样
是在同一个地址空间里面
所以这个内核里面
各个部分
它的这种通信
的调用
是完全就是一些
函数调用
或者是这个共存内存
所以是非常非常高效的
完全不需要像微内核一样
就是说你需要做
很多次这个RPC
做Connect switch
完全没有这些overhead
而这个
从安全性看呢
这个框内核
它的内存安全的
这个可信机
Trustic Computing Maze TCB
就有点类似于这个微内核
是一个很少的
实际上我们发现
这个框内核的这个TCB
是比很多微内核的
整个这个TCB都是要小的
所以就像微内核一样
它也是做了划分
然后你只需要
相信很少的部分的代码
所以我们说就是框内核
它可以得到
红内核的安全性
红内核的性能
以及微内核的安全性
这是它的好处
所以我们可以看
就是说
这里的关键
就是说你怎么去
一会你需要一个
一个OS框架
这个框架很神奇
它要同时满足四个性质
第一
它要有一个很强的表达能力
也就是说
你用OS Framework 停用的API
这个API
应该是可以使得说
你可以做出来
实现出来各种各样的OS功能
包括
但不像我前面说的
所有那些竞争管理
内存管理
调度
文件系统
网络协议站
包括各种各样的外设驱动
所有这些功能
必须要都能够正常实现出来
然后
这个OS框架
它还必须要很小
因为这个OS框架
它就是整个内核的
内存安全的TCB
所以要尽量小
同时你不能说
因为用了你这个框架
写OS
就使得这个OS变得很慢
所以它要保证说效率很高
同时最重要的就是说
我们说要内存安全对不对
那什么叫内存安全
就是在RUS里面
我们说一个RUS的crate
或者说一个cool
就比如说OS framework
还是一个RUScrate
它是所谓的完备的是桑的
这个意思就是说
你任何基于crate
写的一个safeRUS的系统
不管crate之上的safeRUS代码
它是什么样的safeRUS代码
只要是能编译通过
也不管说
在执行过程中
这些safeRUS代码
它用多少个现场
它是一个什么样的执行顺序
或者是并发信
去执行
也不管这些safeRUS代码
它接收什么样的输入
你既可能从用户里面就输入
你可能从一些环境
等等方面就输入
不管safeRUS的
它是什么样代码
什么样的执行顺序
什么样的输入
整个RUS系统
都不会出现未定性行为
在RUS里面
所谓的未定性行为
indefined behavior
没有未定性行为
就是内存性行为
有未定性行为的话
就是出现内存性问题
所以我们保证
如果说我们的OS framework
它是sound的话
那么OS framework里面的OS services
无论怎么着
都不会出问题
这里很好玩点在于什么
就是在我们OS这个场景里面
因为OS framework里面
会包括所有外设驱动
外设驱动就是要跟TEY的
不可信的输入
跟hypervisor
跟QMIL
VMM
跟它去交互
从它那边拿到
由TEY给的这些输入
那这些输入是malicious的
是恶意的
这些输入
根据框内核的安全性定义
也应该不会影响
框内核的内存性行
所以可以说
框内核
它天生
或者说内生的
就能够防范
iago tag
任何的iago tag
都不会导致
框内核出现内存性的问题
这是一个很强的安全保证
所以我们做了
业界第一个框内核的实现
就叫新整Srinus
那大家可以看
就是左边这个架构图
这个红色的部分
这个所谓的OS Kepler 框架
我们起名叫OS-TT
就是OS的标准库
然后OS-TT里面
就是我们真正的内核的
Create
这个里面实现了
几乎所有的
这个Srinus的功能
那包括了
超过220个Linux性调用
这是一个很大的量
整体这个项目
有超过11万行的Ross代码
而这个里面只有17%
就是这个红色部分
红色部分里面有安safe rust
也有safe rust
就这里面所有代码
加在一起
是占到整个内核
这个11万行里面的17%
那这个量是远低于
之前的一些
完全是用Ross写的内核
比如说Red Leaf
CCS Talk
这些工作
那同时我们做了非常多的优化
然后我们的实验发现在在
业界广受接受的
这种基准测试上面
这个Srinus新战
它的性能跟Linux
是在同一个水平上的
就是两个性能相比
就是大概1.0的上下
所以呢
我们证明了
这个框内核
它是不只是一个
这个架构
它是一个纸上弹弼
它是可以造出来的
我们的这个新战Srinus
已经证明这件事情是成立的
那这个
这框内核的这个想法
已经得到了
这个国际学术界的
这个一致肯定吧
和接受
我们在这个Usonic ACC25上
这个发表了这个
关于新战
还有框内核的这个论文
那同时呢
这篇论文呢
也是被Usonics
Login
就是Usonics的这个
学术组织的旗舰杂志
邀请
在线
这个杂志在线发表
那这个邀请率呢
是1%
就是说
今年ACC25的
所有这个100篇论文里面
论文论文里面
只有新战
这一篇
被UsonicsLogin邀请
这个在线发表
所以还是非常受重视的
那那个除此之外的话
我们在ACC25上
还有另外一篇论文
是在这个
Srinus新战上面
去做了这种
形状证明
那还有一篇
那个
今年这个SOSP25上
有一篇论文呢
是在
我们在新战上面
如何去做更加
更加可扩展的
同时很正确的
这个内存的管理
所以呢
新战呢
就是它的框内盒
还有它的这个
多个这个创新点
都已经被
国际学术界所认可
那因为时间所限
所以呢
我不能
就是
详细展开
到底有这个框内盒
它里面的这些API是
刚刚说的这个OSD
或者说这个OSP25
API是什么样子
到底
你怎么
你的驱动是怎么写的
可以
不受这一个
雅尔果太攻击的影响
那这个
因为时间有限
我们就不讲
那但是这个效果上
我们可以总结一下
就是说
Linux Approach
Linux办法就是说
你
我们看
就是
左边这个图像就是说
从bug
从memory safety bug
如何呢
后面会导致这个
安全问题
就是说
你先有内存
比如说
整数应算
一出了
比如说
你造出来了一个
不合法的
一个index
比如说你
转换内形
转换错了
或者比如说
有雅尔果太攻击
等等这些原因
会有一些内存性的bug
那这些内存性的bug
会导致
你会产生
这个不合法的指针
一旦你用了
你造出的不合法的指针
是ok的
但是一旦
但你真正用了的话
这个不合法的指针
去做读写的话
就会导致
不合法的内存访问
真正是
由这个不合法的内存访问
这个环节
才会导致
后面的各种各样的内存
真正的是安全漏洞
就是从bug到漏洞的利用
这个是有这么
有这么一些步骤的
那Linux的办法就是说
我去防止这些bug
它的防止
就是做加固
我通过测试
通过发信
通过人工审计
这个防范法
我尽量不会出bug
但是
因为memory safety bug
这个是在任何地方
都可能出现
所以这么防范
其实是
可以说是挂一露万
你很难保证
说完全不会出bug
那新战是不一样
就是在新战里面
我们做的是说
我们允许
由这个也要和tech
它的影响
导致我们会产生
一些不合法的
一些address
或者说
或者说index
都有可能
你产生这东西没问题
但是
你想做
真正去做内存访问的时候
它一定是会通过
我们框内核的
OS框架
提供的API
一些安全的内存抽象
通过它去做内存访问
那实际上
我们是通过
在真正你访问之前
我们的
OS框架提供的这些
对于内存
对于各种底层
这种OS资源的抽象跟封装
我们在那个地方
那个地方的API是很少的
就是完全给你管住
保证不会出现
不合法的内存访问
因为我们知道
我们前面说
在框内核里面
除了框架部分
以外大满的
都是safe rust
所以你用safe rust
你是不可能
随便去直接
认以访问一个地址
那你必须要通过
我们的OS框架
所以我们就在一个
非常小的地方
我们非常小的一个MIR
我们把所有
不合法的内存安全访问
内存访问
我们都管住了
所以我们
在SRN这边
我们是彻底消弥了
这种优雅和的泰克
可能会导致的
内存安全的
漏洞洞
所以这是一个
非常系统性的保证
所以我们可以说
SRN是它比Linux内存安全
比任何其他的RusOS
内核都要内存安全
可以非常
从遥勇力的
根本上去防范ELTEC
这个就是
所谓的内存安全方面的ELTEC
它是怎么攻的
然后我们怎么防的
那现在我们进入
第三部分
第三部分就是说
我们T1肯定是要做IO
对吧
我们做文件IO的过程中
到底有什么样的
内存安全的威胁
到底怎么防
我们可以看
这里有一个新的概念
叫secure virtual disk
安全迅离硬盘
我们聚台说
我们会介绍一个
我们做的一个安全迅离硬盘
叫MLDisk
这么一个工作
那为什么
为T1需要引入
安全迅离硬盘呢
我们这里看
左边这张图
应用程序
它会做各种
访问文件系统
做各种文件的操作
因为文件系统
其实大家知道
很复杂
而且也很多种
Linux里就有很多种
那我们肯定不希望说
为每一个T1都去重新写
文件系统
这个是功能很大
所以我们希望
是让应用程序
可以直接用
不经修改的
一个文件系统
那这个文件系统之后
如果说
它直接
这个文件系统
它直接去访问
这个T1外的
速度去硬盘
那这个就很大的问题
因为比如说
用户一个写了一个数据
给了文件系统
文件系统
直接把这个数据
送出了T1
那T1外的攻击者
它就可以得知
它就可以叫snoop
可以观察到
这个用户数据
到底是什么
那你就用户的
精明性
精明性就没有
对吧
所以为此
我们就可以
怎么访问这个问题
我们就在
不经修改的
T1里的文件系统
下面
我们引入一个
安全的虚拟的硬盘
这不是个真的硬盘
是个逻辑上的一个硬盘
那所有的这个
文件系统
它在做QoR
QoR的这个IO的时候
是把明文的QoR
交给安全虚拟硬盘
安全虚拟硬盘
它可以去做一些
额外的事情
比如说
它一定会加密
加密完之后
才把这个用户的
加密的QoR
写到T1外的
速逐机的host
这个硬盘上面
那这样的话
防止T1外的
攻击者
他去偷亏
这个用户的数据
因为现在加密了
他回不了
那这个是snooping attack
那假如说
你是加密了
可是万一
这个攻击者
他把你加密的数据块
改怎么办
这个叫temporary
就是篡改
那为了防篡改
我们
一般来说
我们这个安全虚拟硬盘
它要除了加密以外
它还要给这个数据块
会配一个mac
Message Authentication Code
就是类似于这个哈希
来保证就是说
除了这个加密数据块
写的硬盘里之后
这个加密数据块
它所对应的这个mac
或者说这个哈希
也要写到硬盘里某个位置
等我读回来的时候
我这个安全虚拟硬盘
它会去验证一下
这个哈希或者是mac
它是不是
就是这个加密数据块
解密的时候
我会跟这个mac
或者哈希验一下
看是不是一致的
如果说B致的话
就说明被篡改了
那这个就可以防范
T5的这个供应者
做所谓的这种篡改
temporary的供应
那除了这个
那除了这个供应
还有什么别的供应呢
比如说
假如说我现在这个
用户有一个数据块
这个数据块
逻辑数据块
比如说是第一百个
第一百个
这个位置是第一百
这个位置的一个逻辑块
这个块我先写了一次
写了一次
会造成就是说
会硬盘里
会留存一个
加密的数据块版本V1
然后以及它的mac版本V1
然后呢
后面我这个用程序
我又更新了一遍
这个逻辑数据块
那在硬盘里
就会留下一个
加密的这个块的版本V2
和它的相对应的
这个新的这个版本的mac
V2
那有没有可能就是说
这供应者
你其实你已经写了
这个V2版本的
这个加密的块跟mac
它把你这个V2
提款成了V1
也就是说回滚
回滚
来让你这个
这个数据块失去这个新鲜性
所以呢
那个为了防这个事情
那我们就还得去用一些
更高级的手段
去发现这个
没有可能去回滚
除此之外的话
这个T1外的供应者
因为它是有特权的
所谓的有特权
就是说
它可以去控制这个T1的
它的生命周期
比如说
比如说这个host OS
它可以随时去把这个T1
给关掉
给杀死
那因为我们知道这个文件系统
或者说存储
这边
它有一个很重要的性能
它是它要保证一致性
或者说叫
这个crash consistency
就是说
你这个文件系统的状态
在任何一个时候
因为掉电
等等一些非常不幸的原因
你写到一半
整个系统crash
那我下回
再把这个系统起回来之后
我的这个文件系统
或者说我的这个持久化的状态
它能够回复到一个
一个合理的一致状态
因为如果说
不一致的话
就有可能这个用户数据
就会错乱
所以呢
这个crushing attack
这个也是在T1里面
一个对持久化数据的
一个很大的威胁
因为在传统来说的话
我们的环境
只有出现一些非常少的情况
才会掉电
才会出现夸张
但是现在在T1的环境的话
就是攻击者是随时可以干这个事情
所以呢
这个snooping, tamper, robot, crashing
都有可能
这各种各样的攻击
那都是这个secure virtual
这个disk
它需要去能够防范的事情
所以这就是为什么
我们需要引入这个
一个secure virtual disk
那secure virtual disk
那我这个右边所写的
就是它要
它要能够
保护T1里的这个块的io
要维护四个性质
叫CIFC
那C就是机迷性
然后integroity完整性
fragment新鲜性
以及consistency移植性
我们把这个四个性质
缩写在一起就是CIFC
然后呢
我们之所以
你说有没有可能说
我们不加一个安全性硬盘
我们去加固这个文件系统
我们给文件系统
加密
加各种办法
那不也行吧
你觉得这个
是不是一个核心办法呢
那这个之所以
我觉得不好
是因为文件系统本身就很复杂
那你在这么一个很复杂的
一个办法里面
让你去给它加安全性质
你就很难说清楚
这个到底是不是
能把这个安全给做好
而且呢
因为文件系统有好多种
对吧
你难道你每一个文件系统
都需要去做很多的修改
然后来去保证这个CIFC
这四种
至少这四种安全性质吧
还有可能有别的攻击
所以呢
我们就不希望这个
每个文件系统都去改
而且也不能改对
所以
所以我们把安全机制
去浓缩到一个
这个跨设备层
会更好一些
那我们看看这个传统来说
这个
安全确定硬盘是怎么做的
那因为我们要保证
这个CFA
这个四种性质
所以呢
通常来说
我们都会需要引入一个叫
merco hash tray
来去保证
那我们来看
比如说
我们假如说我们有一个
就是这里一个
经典的例子就是
ICS-PFS
PFS这个
这个库
它可以保证这个
CFC四种性质
我们看它怎么做的
那那个
假如说我们现在这个
一个安全确定硬盘
它从逻辑上
是有四个块
就是D0,D1,D2,D3
四个块
那这个四块
我们在硬盘上
肯定是要加密的
那为了防止
这些加密的这个数据块
被回滚
那我们会为这个
加密数据块
还会去配一颗
一颗这个
哈希数
就如这个
就是这个图中的这个
绿色所示
就是这个
每一个哈希数的这个节点
它会维护
这个哈希数的页节点
数据块
节点的merc
比如说N1
N1里面
那个
它就是
可以它维护了这个
D2跟D3
的这个
Mac
然后呢
那个
mercletree
它的这个页节点的
这个本身你也需要加密
也需要防篡改
那所以呢
mercletree
它的这个页节点
又由这个非页节点
就是它们的负责点
比如说N1
它会被N0
这边呢去保护
N0的那个
它会去存这个N1的这个Mac
保证说N1
不会被篡改
那同时
因为我们在
比如说
我们去
更新这个多个块
比如说
我们去更新这个
D0
D1D
我们不说这个更多个
我们就说
更新一个D2
更新一个D2的时候
那因为我们在
更新这个D2数据块的时候
我们会更新D2
同时呢
因为D2一改
这个N1的Mac
就会变
所以N1要改
N1一改
N0也要改
所以这就是说
逻辑上
我们写一个块
实际上呢
在硬盘上
我们其实是
要写三个块
那这三个块
假如说
硬盘电
或者是T1
被关了
crush
那就有可能
这三块
可能只写进硬盘里面两块
那如果是这个状态
再次硬盘打开的话
我们就会发现
这个Mac对不上
所以呢
我们就为了
恢复这个
硬盘到一个
一致的状态
我们就需要准备
一个叫
这个Recovery Journal
这个日誌
里面就是
也就是说我们在写
这个
在硬盘里面
去写新的N0N1
还有D2之前
我们要把旧的版本的N0N1
跟D2的内容
我们存到一个journal里面
这样如果断电的话
我们就可以
就是通过这个Recovery Journal
把整个这个硬盘的状态
就是恢复到
之前的一个一致状态
所以呢
我们看到就是说
传统的这个办法
就是加密
然后同时
加什么GoTree
加上Recovery Journal
这个呢
它是有一个很大的
写放大的问题的
就是说
如果你要随机写一个块
比如说D2
实际上呢
你是要写这个2H
这么个这个块的
这个H呢
就是这个MortalTree的
这个深度
或者高度
所以这是有一个很
很大的写放大的问题
所以传统的办法
它的这个
随机写性能是很差的
那为了解决这个问题
我们就提出说
我们有个insight
就是说
应该使用这个
就基于日治
就是做日治Logging
这个办法
来去
来去构建这个
安全
安全讯定硬盘的方案
因为Logging呢
它第一呢
就是
之前有非常多的工作
就是说明这个
Logging就是要做顺序写
顺序写呢
它比较
它无论是对于这个
物理硬盘
机械硬盘
还是对于这个SSD
都是更加友好的
所以都能有更好的
这个裸设备
裸的这个存储设备的这个性能
那第二呢
这个Logging呢
它对于这个安全性有很大的好处
为什么呢
因为
因为所谓的Logging
就是说你的这个数据
它是要只追加
的话
那么
我们可以看到前面说
就MAT为什么差呢
MAT
它是在随机器的时候性能差
如果说你的这个
数据
它只是在最后追加
那么这个MAT
它实际上的那个
它的性能呢
是并没有这么加的问题
所以呢
如果说我们是
我们的这个存储方案呢
它底层的是
基于Append Only的一个Log
或者是多个Append OnlyLog
它就可以用MAT去保护
或者你即使不用MAT
你可以把这个
一个Append Only的这个Log呢
用这个
用一个一个的这个MAT
就是前一个
每一个MAT
它会寄前一个块的这个MAT
这么招的给串起来
就像这个驱花链一样
那这样的话
你就可以保证就是说
你有一个
一个真实的
一个不可能被篡改的
一个现行的历史
就像驱花链一样
保证一个Chain的
就是这个
所谓的Chain的MAT
而且呢
这个Logging
实现
所谓的Crash Consistency
有很多帮助
因为Logging
就意味着说
它不会轻易地覆盖数据
而不覆盖数据
就意味着说
因为我是在
后面追加数据
那这样
如果中间出现了Crash
那我们只需要丢弃掉
最后的那些
洗到一包的数据
新的数据就可以了
那个老的数据
其实还在
所以Logging
还是有助于
减化Crash Consistency
所以我们的这个想法
就是说
从这个idea上
我们呢
用三种Log
就是数据这一部分
我们
你可以认为
就是Logging上
它是一个
加安密的一个数据日制
比如说
当我们要去更新
第二的时候
我们不复写第二了
而是
我们在
另外一个位置
写一个
第二的新版本
就第二片
那我们
那这里有个问题
就是你要新的位置写
这可以
就是你追加写
这个性能比较好
但是第一
你下回读回
这个第二的时候
你怎么知道这个第二
这个
它在哪个位置呢
对吧
那第二呢
除此之外
就是
这个第二
这个块呢
它到底
它的这个Mac
到底是什么样子
对吧
那这个你也不知道
所以呢
我们就需要
引入一个锁影
那这个锁影
就是中间这个绿色部分
就是我们需要
用这个LSMTree
这个技术
我们利用一个新的锁影
这个锁影
它就可以去记住说
每一个逻辑块
就是逻辑块2
它在硬盘里
到底它的位置
到底是哪个位置
同时
它的Mac是什么
然后呢
对
然后这样
然后就是
因为我们
是在这个
后面追加去写
所以呢
我们的这个
日治的写入
也可以大大的简化
我们只需要
每次去写入
这个很少量的这个数据
而不是
而不是像之前
这个GNMT的方案
你需要在这个日治里面
把这个旧的这个
数据写进去
我们现在只需要去
记一些原数据
那这样的话
这个日治部分的
这个写入量也会很少了
所以呢
这个是我们一个
基本的想法
那这个
稍微再给点背景
就什么叫这个LSMTree
就LogStructureMortree
那这是一个
其实是一个
非常经典的存储方面的
一个技巧
在非常多的
这个
所谓基于这个KV的
这个Store里面
都会去用的一个技术
那简而言之呢
就是说
我们怎么
就是LogStructure
LSMTree
它是一个为写优化的
一个用来寄这个
key value do
这么一个存储技术
那简来说
就是说我每次
去write一个
组上角开啥
每次去write
一个
一个KV的这个
寄入的时候
我先不写硬盘
我先写到一个内存的
这个
经过排序的
一个Vtable
可能是用一个跳标
去实现了一个
有序的一个
一个表
然后当这个表满了之后
比如说达到了
比如说达了100兆
那我们会把整个
这个内存表
我们会把它
会去整体做优化
因为是整体做优化
所以呢
这个每次写的
就是一个
很批量的一个顺序的写
就是相当于是写Log了
那所以呢
在这个硬盘里面
你就会有很多的
MapTable
它被持续化的时候
就叫这个SSTable
那这样的话呢就是
就是所有最新的数据
它都在这个
第零层里面的
SSTable里面
然后呢
那个定期呢
当这个Level0里的SSTable
它比较多的时候呢
就会做这个
所谓的这个Compaction
就是把
这个上一层的这个SSTable
会
这个融到这个下一层
那那个
然后跟下一层的这些SSTable
它会去Merge
那这样的话呢
就是所有的
就是整个这个硬盘里的
就是你
就是你可以看到就说
整个硬盘里面
它是分了很多层
每一层呢
相当于这个SSTable
都是一个日质
都是一个Log
它不经修改
它里面的数据是排过去的
那这样最坏情况就是说
就是我如果像想去
这个查询一个
一个key value的这个记录的话
那么我
需要去从L0或L1到Ln里的
每一层只需要找一个SSTable
我最坏是找N次
N层
就可以找出这个
KV的这个记录
而这个写的时候呢
它是非常非常高效的
因为你只需要这个顺序写
写到这个
就是所有的顺序写
每一层都是Log
这个就是Logstrasher Mercury
这个它的这个特点
那这个特点就对我们
受很多的帮助
因为因为如果说
我们用这个Logstrasher Mercury
然后来去
维护我们的这个
一些数据的话
那这里就是说
所有的这些SSTable都是一个Log
这个Log
它的这个保护起来
我们就可以
非常高效的使用这个IMRT保护起来
好,所以呢那个
所以总来说
就是我们这个
基于日日的这个approach
它就会
达到一个什么效果
就是说
它的这个写放大会非常低
当你随机去写
一个第二这个块的时候
实际上的那个
你只需要去
在这个index 这边
去追加一个
一个KV的记录
就是比如说
记了这个
第二这个块
它最新的
密钥是什么
最新的MAC是什么
以及它最新的
这个物理地址是什么
你只需要记一个记录
这个是比一个块
是很小很多的
然后同时
你可能需要记一点元数据
再尊重一些元数据
所以说
那个这个写放大因子
成了一个E加EPS
EPS是一个元小于的数
那这样的话
我们的随机解析
就会远远好于
之前的基于MAT的传统方案
那那个
所以这个就是
我们提出的一个叫
MLSDisk的一个
一个安全虚拟硬盘的方案
那这个
所谓的MLS
就是它是一个multi-layer的
一个lock structure
就是多层的
基于日日的
一个安全虚拟硬盘
那为什么
我们也需要搞很多层呢
就是因为我们希望让
这个对于
这个安全虚拟硬盘方案
它的安全分析
是非常直接
非常可靠的
而不是说
这个系统非常复杂
一直于我们分析不出来
到底安全不安全
那为什么我们要
就是对于
这个安全硬盘
它的这个复杂性
需要做控制
需要做很好的分层呢
是因为我们前面
看到就是说
我们的这个方案
它是逻辑上是比较复杂的
因为呢
你要维护
你
首先的这个LSMT
它是一个
蛮复杂的数据结构
它里面设计到
有很多个sd table
还有一些额外的一些log
然后呢
我们还要去管这个skill journal
而且呢那个
因为我们是要追加写
所以这里设计到说
我们怎么去管理这个硬盘空间
什么时候去对这个
之前不需要的这个数据块
什么时候做回收
所有这些都意味着
我们的这个方案啊
它逻辑上
看起来是比较简单
但实际上这里面有非常多的
细节需要处理
那任何这个细节出的问题
都会导致我们的方案
会被攻击
所以呢
我们就需要
做一个非常好的分层
把这个事情呢
能够说的非常清楚
那我们一共
把这个mRNA
这个我们的方案里面呢
我们做了四层
就是最上这一层呢
是叫可信的框层
那然后呢
然后
这个L3
L2是这个
我们叫
Transactional的
KVStore的层
在下面呢
是一个Log 认识层
所以下面是一个general层
那这个层
它有几个特点
就是说
首先呢
每一层
每一层从L0开始
它都可以保证这个CFC
就是每一层
它的存储的源于可能不一样
比如说L0只能是做journal
只是说
我可以去顺序的
去记一些journal的
日质的记录
只能顺序的报号加
而且每一个都是很小的记录
每一层的能力可能不一样
作为存储的能力
可能是不一样的
因为最上层是一个
完全是一个跨设备了
每一层的能力是不一样的
但是每一层都要保证
我们这个TE的
防疫亚果Tag就是CFC
机密性
完整性
新鲜性
一致性
四种性质
而且每一层
它只干一件事情
它很薄
然后我们不断当上磊加
每一层
我们都在上一层记录之上
我们会增加
增强我们的存储能力
比如说
最下面这层只是一个journal
在这往上
我们就做出来了一个
基于这个journal
我们就做出来一个
相当于是一个迷你的
文件系统
就是这个文件系统
它的所有文件都是log
这就是logstore
然后有这个logstore之后
我们可以管理多个日治之后
我们就可以造出来
所谓的transactional
KVstore
这KVstore就是
我们前面说的LSMT
LSMT里面
就会有很多的相当于是log
而有了KV之后
我们可以用KV来去做
一个安全的日治
一个index
然后来去实现最上层的
跨设备层
然后为什么安全分析变得简单
你可以看
我们每一层的
所有的每一层的原数据
都是存到了下一层里面
就是L3的原数据
它是存在了L2里面
也就是说
L3它可以保证自己的
原数据是安全的
L3只需要去管说
它的L3的数据
你看L3的最右边的箭头
L3的数据
是直接存到不可信的硬盘里的
所以L3它会去负责
基于L3已经认为是
安全的原数据
来去管理和保护
L3的数据
这个数据写到了
完全不安全不可信的
这个换设备里面
然后L2
它的原数据和数据
都是写到了L1的层里面
所以L2
实际上它根本就不需要去
顾及安全情况的事情
它只需要把L2自己做好
然后L1的原数据
是存在L0里面
所以L1的原数据
可以保证是安全的
L1它只需要去管说
在我原数据的安全的情况下
我L1的这些数据
也就是说
这些logstore
这些log
它的原数据的安全情况下
log里面的内容
是不是安全的
这个内容是直接存到
这个不可信的硬盘里的
所以L1会涉及到说
它要去做
它要去做它自己的数据加密
最后SecureJournal这一层
因为SecureJournal
它已经是作为一个存储的
原语
它的功能是非常简化了
非常简单了
所以SecureJournal
它会直接去跟
不安全的硬盘达到
去把它的原数据
跟数据都存到不可信的硬盘里
但是因为这一层功能很简单
所以我们可以非常直观的
非常有信心的保证说
我们的SecureJournal
它确实是
可以把它的数据跟原数据
存在不可信的硬盘里面
原来是安全的
OK
所以后面因为时间
有限
我这里就不再具体展开每层了
但是基本上的意思就是说
每一层它因为使用了
比如说这L3
它里面的每一张表
都是使用的是下面什么东西
而它只用考虑它自己
额外的数据方面的
怎么保证安全
所以每一层都已经
被了相当的简化
比如说L2
L2它完全是
L3的处理
完全是使用LE提供的原语
而LE
它的原数据是
基于AddedJournal
就是L0提供的
而LE它只需要去
引入一个mercletray
mercletray
来保护它的数据
不会出问题
而SecureJournal部分
它的功能是非常简单的
所以它可以直接去
通过一些密码学的办法
然后来保护Journal的
Journal的框
在硬盘里的安全性
我们的MLTIS
它的实现是一个
通用的实现
我们已经通过一个比较好的分层
把核心部分
跟与OS相见容的部分
去做了个分离
可以使得说
MLTIS它可以给Linux
可以使
可以给Alcum
可以给Srinux
也可以甚至
可以跑在Linux用户态
作为一个用程序
然后来一方面做测试
然后MLTIS它的性能是非常好的
比在FIO
跟Trace
基于一些Trace的
Bunchbox上面
我们看到
它的比PFS
SPPFS会高出7-21倍
以及1-4-36倍的性能优势
今天我们基本上就把TUS
这方面的内容
给大家做了一个讲解
TUS它是一个
截然而言之
就是T1的软件
跟T1硬件之间的一个桥梁
TUS我们可以分成两大类
一种就是给Enclave时的库槽系统
另一类是给CVM时的GasOS
不管是T1的应用程序
还是TUS
Iago Attack
Iago攻击
都是最大的安全威胁
Srinux新战OS
它是对内存安全的
Iago Attack是有一个非常好的防范的
而MLDisk这种安全据令盘
它可以提供非常强的
这种CNFC的安全保证
在各种Iago Attack的面前
好
这就是这次的课程
感谢大家的参加
谢谢